Speaker 1: All right. Let's hear from some people
in the audience. I want to start today with Josh
from Delaware. We take calls via Discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Josh,
welcome. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Awesome. First time caller. Glad to
be here. Yeah. So definitely wanted to talk about
last week. I know one of the big things that gets
talked about a lot of is the election lies. And
you know I do have some friends that always talk
about election was stolen. It was stolen. There's
so much evidence. But where is the evidence?
I just kind of wanted to hear from you on. Has
anyone ever sent you anything? Just showcasing
any evidence of election fraud at all?
Speaker 1: No. I mean, many people all
the way up to make pillow have said as soon
as we get off this interview, I'm going to
send you all the evidence from my cyber guys
or whatever. They've never sent any evidence
at all. Sometimes they will send me a link to that
Dinesh D'Souza movie, 2000 Mules. But of course,
even that doesn't have any evidence. It just has
video of people dropping off ballots at drop boxes
with ominous music playing and some geolocation
data that doesn't actually prove anything. And,
you know, the I'm willing to work forwards,
which is show me the evidence from which I
can draw a conclusion. And if the conclusion
is that the election was stolen by Joe Biden,
I will tell you, after this many years of claims
with no evidence, I'm starting to wonder whether
maybe the evidence doesn't exist. Josh.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David. And I have
one more follow up question pretty quick. But
Fox News, you know, I know one of the other
things has always been the pretty recently the
text messages that were sent privately between
the Fox news host, especially with Tucker
Carlson. Yeah. Kind of your thoughts on that.
How how can people still watch Fox News out
of that information was released? And I also
got to say, I don't remember Tucker even
denouncing that. Those messages weren't
even him. So how can people still watch Fox News
and believe that's still a good news organization
to get there? But there are daily news from.
Speaker 1: Primarily the answer is that Tucker's
viewers either will never hear about the text
messages in which Tucker says he despises Trump,
or they will explain it away by saying, well,
Tucker had to say that for this reason or that
reason, but he didn't really mean it.
Or they will say he has since changed
his mind. They'll explain it away one way
or the other. They seem pretty committed
at this point. To Tucker and to Fox News.
Speaker 2: Got it. Well, thanks, David. Appreciate
your time and hope you have a good rest your day.
Speaker 1: Pleasure. There is Josh from Delaware.
Very, very much appreciate that. Remember
to ideally get right to your question,
and I love that everybody's got their
correct audio devices selected today